is it a director's job to make an actor
feel safe yes probably the most
important job of anything a director
does because the actor is to some extent
putting themselves in your hands because
you're the judge you're you're watching
what you're doing and you have to be
careful not to let them look bad so you
want them to not feel because the
problem is that if it if an actor
develops a distrust for the director
and they feel like they're going to
direct themselves
it's problematic because now the feeling
is that maybe I don't want to take a
chance I don't want to do this I don't
want to be too big here because I can't
trust this person to tell me if I'm
being too big
uh and so now you get a guarded
performance that's not real not true so
you want to try and in some ways with
actors you're just meeting you can only
do it by virtue of working together and
trying like proving it
um but you you do want to make them feel
like look I will not let you look bad uh
and you're safe and I want you to try
give me everything just don't be afraid
and and together we'll find the right
tone and the right way to do it
um so it's it's about building trust
it's the most important thing
what do you think they're afraid of
looking bad at it they're overacting I
think overacting or underacting or just
you know uh because you're always as a
direct director I think you always have
to remember that it's the actor's ass
that's out there you know that that
actors on that screen they're being
judged uh people in the audience not
saying gee that director I don't know
you know I think you gave him a bad bad
piece of advice that they'll just look
at the actor and they're responding the
actor is making me feel I believe him or
her or I don't
um so that's a heavy responsibility for
an actor to carry it's scary frightening
us I think they're so brave
so they're going to go out there in this
tightrope
and they got to be sure that you're
going to be able to tell them when
they're they're stepping a little bit
too fur you know to follow to the left
and they're going to fall
um uh because I think I can't imagine a
more bitter experience for an actor than
to watch themselves on screen and think
oh my god look how big I was there
and the director didn't catch it you
know I'm now I look like an idiot
you can't always know if you're an actor
if it's too big or too small or you know
so I miss that opportunity so it's a
it's a big possibility for a director
you know it's a it's a scary
responsibility but one reason I love
working with actors I've worked with
before
it's great people have relationship with
and we trust each other we know each
other we have that shorthand it's a
really nice feeling
I think a lot of newer actors are afraid
to look too big I like how you said that
go big like you know
and you know don't don't let them take
this scene away from you I thought that
was brilliant yeah I mean I do think you
always have to be careful uh you know
just about because the camera is
you know the camera sees things more
clearly than the naked eye and you know
close up and uh you remember we were we
were discussing a car mold and you know
earlier today actually what a wonderful
guy was a great actor kind of under even
though he's Oscar winner but his
underrated actor and I did a movie with
him and it was a feature film and it was
shot on film and so I'm doing his
close-up
and I'm watching and I I just wasn't
sure he was getting there I I was
nervous and I was only like 26 or
whatever at the time
and so I I didn't quite have the courage
to say to Carl mold and Oscar winner
Ilya Kazan working you know actor uh hey
Carla could you be a little so I just
kind of let it go I thought okay if if
this doesn't work in the dailies I'm
gonna try to find a way to reshoot this
tomorrow and I'll I'll just have to
approach it with him
but when I saw the dailies
it was a whole different performance
what was happening in his eyes and a
little thing in his mouth and you know
he had a Mastery of of his his
instrument
and it was invisible on the street to
the naked eye of me standing there three
feet behind the camera but on the screen
I saw and I was so glad I didn't you
know say Carl could you make that a
little you know I would have given
myself away you know novice which of
course no one respected otherwise anyway
but it was a great lesson that that film
actors you know especially experienced
great film actors know exactly how to
modulate
um their their performance depending on
where the camera is and sometimes you
can see it with a naked eye sometimes
you can't what do you think about actors
giving you a different performance each
take
you know it's um it's a healthy thing I
think it's you know as long as you've
gotten the performance that you need you
know that it gets Troublesome if if you
you still haven't gotten what you really
felt to see needs and now we're trying
something different
but I think uh
in the right circumstances it's great to
have it in The Cutting Room and
sometimes they'll cover something like
wow you know and oftentimes with actors
um I'll I'll just sort of uh if I feel
like they they have this this gift
um once we get a take I like and I'm
printing it and I'm ready to move on
sometimes I'll just say you know let's
just try one more and go nuts let's see
what happens
and most actors love that some don't but
most do and and you get something that
could be just amazing uh or not but it's
worth going for and you have the safety
of knowing you have what you you know
what you need
um there's a moment where it gets
abusive
in that the actor never wants to move on
um I haven't really had an experience
I've seen other directors have it
and it's a little bit of a nightmare
where you say Okay 55 takes and you know
I don't want to direct this in The
Cutting Room I'm directing it here so
anyway so um that's sort of the danger I
guess but I love when an actor has a
different way of doing things and wants
to try something different than feels
free enough you know to do that I think
it's great and should be encouraged what
if a director can tell that something is
untruthful or not working with an actor
in a scene how do you approach the actor
it's it's a tricky and difficult thing I
I find anyway
um but I think the most important thing
to keep in mind
is to speak first of all privately and
quietly with the accurate that's you
know I've visited people on sets and I
uh I see these directors over them in
video Village at the Monitor and uh no
you're not funny enough you gotta It's
gotta be funny make them laugh you know
and the actors oh my God I just think
that's horrible yeah so I tend to after
every take even if I don't have a note I
will go to the actor and just you know
hey doing good this is great you know I
just want to talk about something uh
softly because if you give an actor an
adjustment publicly
now everyone's watching and they know
now they're being judged do they get
this note do they nail it it's still not
right you know it's a little bit
so I just try to work very privately
with the actor and just give them just a
gentle thing and I never
um
you're giving them as I said I've got a
line reading uh I just try to get them
to ask themselves questions about what's
you know what will you what are you
feeling here you know and if I if I feel
something's wrong it's not working I'll
just I'll just say to them so what are
you feeling in this you know in this
scene
and they'll tell me and sometimes that's
like ah of course so that's not at all
what we're really doing here and I'll
say to them well
try this you know what if you're feeling
this this this this and usually they'll
go with that you know if and there's
always a moment where they nope nope
nope I don't want to do that you know
then now you're in the bad actor
director your nightmare which is very
hard for the director to win on this
year
but I find that most of my relations
with actors has mostly been really
healthy and positive and respectful
and you know I sort of get
um the courage it takes to do what they
do
and I do feel because as a writer
sometimes you get locked into a certain
Cadence you hear about the line the way
the line has to be spoken and and the
actor doesn't see it that way and
they're not saying it that way and if
it's really egregious I might say to him
some things that were her something
specific as I'd love to hear that just
with the emphasis on that word instead
of this word and see how that you know
and I get a good result sometimes
sometimes I don't and what I've learned
is that you just have to let it go at a
certain point if the actor is just not
doing it either they're trying hard to
do it if they don't hear it the way you
hear it uh it's going to be false if
they force themselves to do it so many
times I just have to walk away thinking
I'm not going to force them and the
reality is you're the only one in the
world who knows that there was a
different meaning about that line or
different emphasis on that line so it's
always going to bother me when I hear it
but no one else
is ever going to notice it or feel it
and so you have to kind of let go and
and you know not not make everything so
precious because an actor if you cast
the right actor you want them to bring
to the table their interpretation their
quirks their ideas and it's going to
sometimes bump up against yours and uh
unless it's something that's really
story altering you know I almost always
go in favor of what the actor wants to
do uh unless it's just you know it's
crazy but I trust their instincts and
they know it works for them and so I'm
usually happy to do it and then by the
same token if an actor ever asks for
another take
yeah absolutely and that can get abusive
too it could be a point where they don't
want to move on they're just going to
you know let me try one more time but uh
I I think you're crazy even though you
might have to take it you think is
fantastic that's a great take I'm ready
to move on you want to move on you have
to move on
but the actor says can I just try one
more you got it you got to do it because
it might be something incredible even if
it isn't the actor knows that they're
heard and that they got their shot and
that you're not going to just cut them
off